what about
bitcoins comparison to other current
cryptocurrencies so
bitcoin versus ethereum for example
why um is it possible that ethereum
overtakes bitcoin
it's certainly possible yeah i'm not
ruling it out
um ethereum leadership is sort of wise
enough
to understand that they shouldn't
compete with bitcoin
on those most profound qualities
like ethereum doesn't really aspire to
be more
um sound from a monetary perspective
than bitcoin
right the in fact the ethereum
leadership very sort of constantly
tweaking the monetary policy
so they went for a completely different
trade-off right
they also don't compete to be as
decentralized from a governance
perspective
right because there's leadership there's
an eth foundation
there's a charismatic leader of italic
and
ethereum has this policy of hard forks
so
in bitcoin hard forks are extremely rare
in ethereum
it's the default way to change things so
it's a much more adaptive system
and it changes more frequently but that
also means that it's
sort of they're incurring more risk when
they introduce those changes there's
much more complexity so
ethereum is smart because they sort of
understood bitcoin as the top dog when
it comes to a sound money
a digital gold type thing and they went
for
all of the different trade-offs they
wanted to be
more of a platform they wanted to have
more complexity
the transactional layer they wanted to
take on more risk in terms of changing
the protocol they wanted to change more
quickly
they wanted to make the monetary policy
more mutable
so ethereum takes that completely
different tack
of course you know i'm not ruling out
that it could take over bitcoin
from a market cap perspective it's just
a very different system
and i tend to think that bitcoin is the
most disruptive one
because it's the most equipped to
challenge
sovereign currencies in the grand scheme
do you think they can
co-exist so like in the future
is do you see a world where you know
ethereum captures some large percent of
the market
and but nevertheless the minority
a hundred percent 100 bitcoin has
already been tokenized
and put onto ethereum many units of
bitcoin i think over a billion dollars
worth
so not only do they coexist they are
actually mutualistic
so they're like two creatures that have
this you know it's like the
the rhino and like the bird the pecks
the parasites off the rhino's back or
whatever
yeah right so i don't know which is
which in the analogy
but yeah i don't know who the parasites
are
yellow or you know the alligator and the
teeth cleaning fish or whatever right so
oh you know i always wonder why the
alligator doesn't just
eat the fish but i guess they're
brushing its teeth basically so
ethereum is it gives you more
transactional flexibility there's
much more experimentation happening
there it has this whole decentralized
finance
element there's a huge number of
bitcoins that circulate
on the ethereum protocol right because
ethereum
is open to other asset types basically
so
i think that's actually accretive to
both systems
because ethereum gets to have this good
form of collateral bitcoin
on the system which is good volatility
characteristics
and then it's a supply sync for bitcoins
which are sort of now they're injected
into this third-party protocol
and that i think reduces the velocity of
bitcoin overall and it's probably good
for the valuation
so you see it it quite possibly could be
a symbiotic relationship
that's really interesting i think so i
think so
you